here it is here's the original one I
think there's this misnomer that my
orange code it's dead but no it's just
dying quickly there's just a good amount
of this going on but I think this thing
has a couple more years for sure so this
is my desk I sit here all day and I work
and I look at this map whenever I'm
daydreaming I just look at this map
I bought this map off eBay and it was in
like an elementary school and now it's
in my office I noticed something every
time I look at it that kind of irks me
that something is this this 0 this 0
which is not just one number but it's
actually a corresponding line that looks
like this
[Music]
let's back up here for a second the
earth is divided into line sometimes
they're curved like they are on my map
and whether or not their curves are
straight has to do with this concept of
projection which is I'm not going to
talk about here I've talked about plenty
using a knife and a globe back in an old
Vox video that I made but just know that
the earth is divided up into lines
latitude and longitude lines ones they
go up and down and ones that go from
side to side all of these lines in the
grid have a number associated with them
so for the up-and-down lines there's a
zero point and then anywhere to the
right of that or east of that starts to
go up from zero to a hundred and eighty
with a little e next to it for east of
the zero line and then everything to the
left or the west of it has the same
thing zero to 180 with a W for West okay
that center point is the zero point from
which all East and West things are
measured the same thing for these
side-to-side lines if you go up from
here you're gonna start to get higher
and higher until you get to 180 degrees
north or if you go south you will go 180
degrees south which is the South Pole
finding out where the zero point should
be for these horizontal lines is
actually quite easy the earth has these
two natural poles which make for a
natural top and bottom of the earth and
halfway in between those two poles you
have this perfect center point the
equator which is a very natural place to
put this zero point and to measure
everything from the up and down lines
are totally arbitrary where you decide
them like who's to say that like it
couldn't be right here in Russia and
this could be zero and everything could
go west and east from here or Japan for
that matter well in fact a long time ago
that's how it used to be
these maps with these grids were really
really important for navigating the
world and so that everyone had to choose
a zero point and most would just make
their capital or their home base
the zero point if you lived in Japan you
would just make Japan the zero point and
the rest of the coordinates would be
measured against that one zero point
which was Japan and same if you lived in
France or Washington DC this was fine
because back then countries kind of just
fought Wars and competed with each other
they weren't really collaborating or
aligning or trading as much as they do
today and so everyone could just have
their own maps centered around their
place and they did just find but then
around the 1800s a few things started to
happen that completely changed
everything first countries and empires
instead of just competing and fighting
with each other started to actually say
like we should align with each other and
trade and be friends because that's
better for everyone pair this with the
fact that map making and sea navigation
was becoming like a big industry it was
no longer just the king ordering maps to
be made for there like expeditions but
now it was like private businesses going
out and doing things that private
businesses do and so there was now like
a demand for good seafaring maps in
short mat making was trending seems like
a pretty good time to be alive okay and
there was one more thing that was
happening around this time that was
super important which is this trains
trains everywhere trains were just like
popping up everywhere and trains were
also trending people were now able to
travel like across the country not just
like on their horses but on this whole
system of trains where you buy a ticket
get on a train and end up somewhere
hundreds of miles away
you know what trains run on the sides
pole is time timetables schedules how do
you know when your trains gonna arrive
and when it's gonna leave and when it's
gonna get their time some Universal set
time the problem is back in the 1800s
there was no Universal set time check
out this piece of paper today all of
these cities and towns would be just on
Eastern Standard Time one
time zone but back then every town had
their own time depending on when it was
noon for them if they were a little bit
east or a little bit west of here that
would be different than in Washington DC
total nightmare for trains the lifeblood
of trains is time and this time mishmash
just wasn't gonna work okay so what does
all of this have to do with this look at
this guy you probably don't know who
this person is I didn't know who this
person was
he was the US president that no one
remembers this US president in the late
1800s saw a problem with all of this
he realized that having a bunch of
different maps with a bunch of different
zero points based on whoever was making
it was a problem and he realized that
not having a universal timezone or some
sort of universal way of making the same
time for everyone was also a problem so
he invited 41 countries to come here to
Washington DC where I live and to sit
around and think and talk about where
this zero point should be where should
the center of the world be so that we
can measure time as well as navigation
all maps could be normalized to this one
spot so after a moment of a bunch of
white dudes sitting around in a room in
Washington DC which is kind of what's
happening today in Washington DC they
came to a vote and that vote you know
almost unanimously said that the zero
line should be right here
[Music]
this line if you zoom in goes right
through London England it actually goes
through a little outskirts town called
Greenwich Greenwich is the home of the
Royal Observatory of the British Empire
this would be the place where the Prime
Meridian or the zero point for the
entire world
East and West would start every country
at the conference agreed that this
should be the case except for the
Dominican Republic at that time called
Santo Domingo they said no they were the
one country that didn't like this
proposal and France and Brazil actually
abstained diplomatically which was kind
of them saying like oh we don't agree
with this France continued to make their
maps with Paris as the center point but
eventually they got on board as well so
that gets to the crux of my big question
of why the zero right there which is a
bunch of people voted on it but why were
they so down with Britain having the
zero point being in the center of the
world well the answer is because it was
1884 and Britain was just really good at
the ocean the British Empire was by far
the biggest most powerful Navy that had
the most experience with maps and ocean
faring and so it was kind of a natural
choice to let Britain the king of the
ocean have this center point and from
then on maps started to be drafted with
Greenwich this Royal Observatory as the
center point for the east-west divide in
the world over time this exact point
exactly where it's drawn has shifted a
tiny bit because of better tools to
measure things and so it's actually a
like not literally on the Royal
Observatory anymore but it's effectively
in the same place that was drawn in this
1884 conference but they also
established that all time in the entire
world would be measured against this
same spot Greenwich Noon at Greenwich at
the Royal Observatory would be the peg
against which all other time was set
they called this Greenwich Mean Time
so you end up getting a map that looks
like this
[Music]
zoom in and you see Greenwich is right
here that's GMT Greenwich Mean Time
okay you go west of here and you start
to get GMT minus 1 or minus 2 minus 3
you can come all the way back to the
East Coast the United States and this
time zone is Greenwich Mean Time minus 5
right now sometimes it's minus 4 if
there's daylight savings and daylight
save it's dumb and whatever but you get
the idea
the more you go west you go back from
Greenwich Mean Time if you go east it's
the opposite you go forward to Greenwich
Mean Time so if it's noon at Greenwich
then this next timezone it would be 1
p.m. 2 p.m. 3 p.m. 4 p.m.
etc so these time zones have been marked
up in these kind of strange shapes
eventually if you go 12 steps away from
Greenwich 12 time zones you'll end up
here at this mess this mess is the
International Dateline this is where
Greenwich Mean Time plus 12 or minus 12
ends up at this line which is where a
new day starts so let me give you an
example of what this would look like
imagine it's 4:00 p.m. in Greenwich
England right here at this world
observatory it is 4:00 p.m. GMT on May
28th if anyone wants to send me a
birthday gift May 28th May 20th it's May
28th to 4:00 p.m. GMT Greenwich Mean
Time sitting and chilling in the Royal
Observatory which I've never actually
been to I need to go to the rule
observatory I go to the Road observatory
I'm going to do that this year next year
at some point okay so it's 4:00 p.m. May
28th
across the ocean here in Washington DC
at that time you can see that we go from
4 p.m. - 5 so 11 a.m. ok so it's 11 a.m.
here in Washington DC at that exact time
on May 28 head across the United States
to the west coast of the United States
to Seattle or Portland and right there
it's three hours earlier than it is here
you're now at 8 a.m. so it's 8 a.m. here
it's still 4 p.m. and Greenwich it's
still 4 p.m. in London now you head into
the Pacific Ocean keep going west until
you get to French Polynesia at which
time it's 5:00 in the morning
you're now GMT - 11:00 it's 5:00 in the
morning and then you get right up to
this messy line if you were to be in the
Baker Islands which is like a us like a
random uninhabited island in the middle
of the Pacific Ocean you would be at 4
a.m. so it's 4 p.m.
over in Greenwich it's 4 a.m. on this
random island in the Pacific so then
cross this messy-looking line it's still
4 a.m. but now it's the next day it's
May 29th at 4 a.m. here in Fiji
at the same time 4:00 p.m. at Greenwich
it's now 4 a.m. the next day may 29 2012
hours in front of Greenwich just by
going over this International Dateline
you could do this exact same thing going
the other way start heading east and you
see that you know it's 5:00 p.m. and
6:00 p.m. and 7:00 p.m. head all the way
over into Asia and now you're getting
closer to seeing how that 4:00 a.m.
happens when you get over to Fiji now
the caveat to all of us of course is
that some of these countries switch by
an hour for like daylight savings type
things and whatever but ignore that
imagine there wasn't daylight savings
right now in this moment we're daylight
savings is at least n - the United
States this holds across the whole
world someday I'll make a video about
this whole messy debacle but the point
of all of this is to say that because of
this conference in 1884 to reconcile
train timetables and to make maps more
uniform we now have this navigation and
time system that rules our whole world
and Britain is just sitting at the
center of it of course the British
Empire may have fallen and the world has
moved on from Britain being the center
of the world in a lot of ways but it's
still technically the center of the
world in a lot of ways I'm gonna put
some links in the description for some
of these cool tools that kind of help
visualize time zones if you're
interested in that sort of thing
but yeah my question has been answered I
actually didn't know the answer to this
question and I went on a deep dive and
now I know so now I'll sit at my desk
and I will know the answer to why that's
zero and I think that was worth it
so thanks big thank you - Skillshare for
sponsoring this video
Skillshare is this giant repository of
online tutorials where you can subscribe
and have unlimited access to tutorials
about everything you can imagine from
design to entrepreneurial skills to
photography videography it's all there I
learned everything I know with online
tools including skill share and I really
believe in the model of online learning
there's one course in particular that I
would recommend which is this premier
starting course I remember the URIs
which Dover to premier from Final Cut
Pro to edit my videos I knew a lot about
the fundamentals of editing but I found
that going through a course that really
lays out all of the features of Premiere
and refreshes all of the kind of
fundamentals of editing was really
important so even if you are like a
editor who's experienced I think there's
great value in going through and getting
a holistic view of what Premiere can do
and some of the tricks and tips that
maybe didn't learn if you haven't done
these sort of formal trainings because
they sponsored this video they're giving
all of you two months free of unlimited
access to all of these tutorials so you
can try it out see if it's a good fit
for you so click the link in the
description to get those two months free
test it out see if you like it thank you
skill
for sponsoring and thank you all for
watching I will see you in another video
sometime in the future
[Music]